david webb on fox nation david thanks so
much for being with us today uh merry
christmas to you
um
this is a tragic story because both
sides the defense and the prosecution
acknowledged that this
was a mistake that she grabbed the taser
over the gun but that they reached the
conclusion that it was negligent
what are your thoughts on the verdict
well you said it it's a tragic situation
and unfortunately kim potter's life well
is also now ruined but
while many will spend time litigating or
relitigating the case and talking about
it as nuts and bolts the system is
spoken she has the right to appeal there
are other things that i'm sure we'll
hear about this case in the future
i'd rather focus on a message to
criminals and to would-be criminals into
americans writ large
when you don't comply with the police
when you take yourself down a path
where you end up in this type of
situation dante wright was certainly not
innocent i'm not saying he deserved to
die it's a tragic mistake
by the police officer but had he not
gone down that path where he was already
facing prison with felony charges he was
out on a hundred thousand dollars bail
he certainly is not a sinner that should
be turned into a saint and this is
unfortunately what usually happens in
these cases the lesson here is for us to
examine the situation and to take it
forward and say how do we keep our
children and our young people away from
this type of situation and if we do a
better job of that there will be fewer
dante rights and fewer kim potters yeah
i want to get your views on something
else as well vice president kamala
harris reportedly said that her media
coverage would be better if she were a
white man and i want to read you this
from the new york times it says that
miss harris has privately told her
allies that the news coverage of her
would be different if she were any of
her 48 predecessors all of whom were
white and male she has also confided in
them about the difficulties she is
facing with the intractable issues on in
her portfolio such as voting rights and
the root causes of immigration
what do you make of that and let's not
forget her approval rating right now
she's at 43 to prove 50 percent
disapprove what do you say
well she's a progressive so
self-identify as a white man and get
better coverage oh come on really
kavala harris has failed to actually do
her job she probably hasn't opened the
portfolio and looked at it or is
deliberately chosen to ignore what's
there there is a crisis on the border
she's supposed to be the board of
sheriff she's only shown up momentarily
to go to a center she hasn't dug into
the real root causes because this is not
part of the left's agenda the
progressive left of which she is their
leader she's the vice president united
states is now pushing even further on
these open border processes taking them
down to interdict to stop and good for
the state of texas for stepping up i've
been saying it for years where the
federal government fails to do its job
the state must you mentioned a handily
handling at the border there uh well
house democrat has slammed kubler harris
on the border because she she failed to
return his calls henry cuellar uh who
represents a district in texas down
there reached out to her before her
visit he did not hear back from her and
he said this she was tasked with that
job it doesn't look like she's very
interested in this so we're going to
move on to other folks that work on this
issue effectively just giving up on help
from her and having to look elsewhere
what does that say to you
well it says that he recognizes what the
american people see on the daily basis
on that border what they see is a train
wreck of a situation a environmental
nightmare a human trafficking nightmare
drugs crossing the border a saudi
arabian man of interest tied to yemeni
terrorist groups just arrested at the
border what about the ones we don't know
the ones that got away he sees this
reality and the reality is kamala harris
has no interest from attorney general to
vice president she could barely garner
enough attention she was a prop in part
to get president biden elected and now
she's failed as expected but sadly the
failure really comes down on the
american people who are paying the price
not just on the border but across all
communities where this administration is
balkanized in america by inviting
illegals to come in and then using
resources taxpayers of america pay for
to take care of illegal aliens
david thank you so much for joining us
you paint a worrying picture of the
administration we thank you very much
for being here merry christmas to you
thanks david merry christmas benjamin